good morning and welcome to sophie ridge
on sunday
it had seemed like the moment of maximum
danger for the prime minister had passed
sue grey's report into partying at
downing street was published on
wednesday to only a trickle of criticism
from conservative backbenchers but that
trickle could be turning into a steadier
stream and there are rumors that we
could reach the 54-letter threshold that
would trigger a confidence vote in the
prime minister at this point boss
johnson would be feeling pretty
confident he would win that vote but
remember two difficult by-elections are
around the corner and a yougov poll has
suggested that if there was an election
today the conservatives would hang on to
just three of 88 battleground
constituencies if there's one thing that
could push mps into action it's the
thought of losing their seat
[Applause]
well in a moment for the government will
be joined by northern ireland secretary
brandon lewis for labour will be
speaking to the party's chair and shadow
women and equality secretary annelise
dods
we'll be looking at food price inflation
and just how hard it is for those of the
lowest incomes with iceland's managing
director richard walker
rail unions are threatening to bring the
country to a standstill and that could
be a sign of more strikes to come we'll
be talking to the rmt general secretary
nick lynch
and i am delighted to say that i'm going
to be joined live here in the studio by
the ukrainian mp kiera rudick who's been
in the uk meeting politicians here
[Music]
hello good morning well just ahead of
the queen's platinum jubilee the
government is hoping to focus on its
policy to bring back imperial measures
could we see crowns back on pint pots
but of course the talk here in
westminster remains about the prime
minister's future and those allegations
of interference in sugrov's report are
going to be particularly unhelpful for
number 10 as more conservative mps make
it clear they want him to go well we're
joined now by the northern ireland
secretary brandon lewis thank you very
much for being uh with us
um it's been a pretty difficult week for
the government with the publication of
the sue gray report um you've come out
to back for the government not once but
twice i also interviewed you on
wednesday the day of the publication
yes yes i was at hillsborough castle i
was just awaiting the uh arrival of the
u.s delegation to come have dinner and
talk about the issues with the northern
ireland protocol and northern ireland
more generally you've got a bit of a
history though haven't you coming out to
bat for the government on these really
difficult days and i remember talking to
you after matt hancock had been caught
breaking covered rules after market
rashford's free school meal policy i
mean you're hoping that number 10 will
might one day let you out when there's a
good news story to talk about well
actually this week is a as an example
actually we've got a lot of work going
on this week actually in northern
ireland we've had the second reading of
a very very important delicate but
important uh piece of legislation so
it's been a busy week all round i'm
always happy to come out and talk about
what we're doing in government because
we're focused on delivering for people
and getting the job done in a way that
works for people across the uk okay well
of course it's you know just four days
since you were speaking here uh to me
but even in those four days we've had
more allegations coming out around the
publication of the su grey report into
uh partying in downing street during
lockdown now according to the sunday
times i just want to go through what's
in the sunday times today because it
does feel quite significant
on the night before her report she was
apparently lobbied to make changes to it
this is the sunday times simon case the
cabinet secretary samantha jones the
permanent secretary at number 10 and
alex chisholm the permanent secretary to
the cabinet office are understood to
have pressed gray to water down her
conclusions they go on to say
sources said the case
sorry case's name was among those they
wanted to remove
other changes were requested to sections
of the report referring to the prime
minister's wife
carrie
is that true
i i don't recognize any of that and i've
got to say we've had a police
investigation into all of these issues
now they've come to their conclusions
made their decisions and we've had sue
grey and i think i don't think anybody
would question the independence and the
probability of either the police and i
certainly i have to say as i said to you
on wednesday having
worked with sue gray in her previous
roles and my previous roles i would i
wouldn't in any way question sue gray's
independence and determination to
deliver report that she is comfortable
is a full and complete report which is
what she's done you say you don't
recognise this
what does that mean i don't what does
that mean i don't know well look nobody
has said anything of the sort to me that
that reflects what what the times have
uh you've just outlined from the time
but with respect though no one's saying
that they were lobbying you to try and
change no no no the allegation is that
very senior people including simon case
her cabinet secretary were directly
trying to influence the report well as i
say having worked with sue gray in other
areas and actually in her car or not in
the report but in her role as dealing
with union issues and things like that
issue gray wasn't comfortable she
wouldn't be putting the report out she
has put a report out that she is
comfortable with she's an independently
minded as well as doing this in an
independent kind of capacity and a very
professional civil servant so i don't
believe that anybody in knowing sue grey
i don't believe anybody would be able to
pressure sue grey into putting any kind
of report out that she wasn't
comfortable with the full and proper
report the problem is you say you know
sue grey i don't know see great
our viewers don't know steve it's too
great we're just basically taking this
on trust
no no you can go further than that
because don't forget it's not just the
sue grey report we've also had the
police investigation the police have
come together and they find boris
johnson for breaking the law they've
they find the prime minister for once
one so that's actually quite good then
we're not being told that actually it's
good look there's no denying this whole
situation is not good it shouldn't have
happened that's why the prime minister i
think was right to go out and apologize
for that i have to say there were things
that report were reported we spoke
briefly about earlier in the week around
how some of the security and cleaning
staff were it was abhorrent nobody
should be treated like that you're one
team working together for the benefit of
the country whatever your role in it is
it's an important part people should be
treated with respect that's why it's
good that this report was done and were
able to now deal with the issues and the
prime minister's already taken on board
the recommendations from the interim
report and as the final report knows
he's putting those changes into place
has the has anyone managed to identify
who those people were who were supposed
to be abusing the staff yeah i have said
not as far as i'm aware i know the prime
minister has gone and personally
apologized uh to the staff for what they
suffered but i i don't think anybody's
aware of exactly who has committed that
in the first place
but we've got to be clear that kind of
behavior that kind of attitude towards
anybody is completely unacceptable as i
say we're all working together whatever
your role within the government you are
part of delivering form do you think
that those people should be found and
then sacked well that's something that
civil service themselves and number ten
i i know we'll be looking at to get to
the bottom of what happened but i think
the important thing is that those those
people who are treated that way
know that the senior management there
the prime minister who is himself
obviously the lead um the leader there
not just our party but of of number 10
in the government has made it very clear
it's not acceptable and has apologized
them personally for how they've been
treated um one of the things that i'm i
was a bit puzzled about i said on
wednesday as well uh is the fact that
sugray didn't investigate the alleged
abonight party uh in the number 10 flat
that was on november the 13th 2020.
this is the sunday times this morning
and they're talking again about the
alleged pressure on sugree another key
passage to be altered concerned the
alleged abenite party in the prime
minister's flat above downing street on
november 13th 2020. an earlier draft of
the report referred to music being
played
and then it goes on to say
according to two sources stephen buckley
johnson's chief of staff tweaked it on
the eve of the report's publication a
claim denied by downing street so
what's going on there what was there any
tweaking if you like if that well i'd
say again uh a couple of key points
first of all see this is another
situation the police looked at and
people weren't like i finally didn't
find it
yeah i know you're asking about the sue
grave report but but there is an
important fact here that number number
10 down the street are saying this claim
is is not correct that it's it's untrue
and i would say that's backed up by the
fact that the police didn't see anything
there that required anybody being fined
so um i i think the dentistry statement
is a fair statement the problem about
the darling street statement if i'm
going to level with you is that downing
street have apologized for
lying or misleading journalists about
partygate right you know the prime
minister spokesman had to issue an
apology saying there were failures in
both what happened and how it was
handled subsequently and he apologized
for that so how can we trust what
downing street is saying it's a bit like
the boy who cried wolf well a couple of
things again i think that first of all
it's a different down history you've got
a different team of people the chief of
staff is different uh the prime
minister's the same promise but the team
that you're talking about the team that
worked with the prime minister that lead
on these issues and steve barkley
himself is new and wasn't there at the
time of those original
mistakes and issues happen but on top of
that it's not just down history
denying it we've also got a situation
the police have looked at this this
particular set of incidents and didn't
find an issue there to find people can
you come on this program and give us an
assurance a black and white assurance
that nobody
in
downing street in number 10 or in the
server service trying to implement a
security report i'm absolutely confident
that's the case look i wasn't part of
the report i'm not part of the number 10
team that worked with sue ground the
report but as i said and i appreciate
your point about the general public
don't know sue grade but those who have
worked with cross government both people
who but the question isn't about whether
it was
it was about whether that
was attempted yeah no i understand that
but i say anybody who's working number
10 knows sue grey well enough to know
that that kind of wouldn't work and no
i'm confident particularly number 10
have
outrightly made the point and denied
that this happened i am confident that
sue gray had the freedom to write the
report that she was comfortable to write
and publish okay
now currently 34 mps have publicly
questioned the prime minister's uh
position concept and pieces 24 are
calling for him to go as soon as
possible that's according to the sort of
sky news spreadsheet that's been
particularly meticulously kept by our
producer tom larkin do you think that
the prime minister is going to face a
confidence vote
i don't think he will actually i don't
think he's in the interest of the
country i don't think he's interested in
the conservative party and obviously i'm
somebody who was chairman of the party
through the last
prime minister having not only a
confidence vote but i was the chairman
who ran that leadership campaign so i've
seen this from both sides i don't think
he's in anybody's interest no i don't
think we will see that happen the reason
i'm asking is because obviously you know
24 calling from him to go it's still
quite below the 54 needed to trigger a
vote of no confidence but as you all
very well remember when the confidence
vote was triggered in theresa may the
number of people who had letters in was
roughly double the number he'd said
publicly
that they had had done so well first of
all let's be clear that's
that's rumor of supposition nobody knows
how many letters are in one thing i do
know from having been chairman of the
party i worked obviously closely with
grant brady because you run the
leadership campaign between what's
called the 1922 committee and the party
um and what i do know is there's only
one person who knows how many letters
are in and that is grand brady that's
never leaked i doubt it ever will leak
um and so anybody who's
debating what the numbers were about
they now are today it is pure
supposition isn't that the point right
that we don't actually know how many
letters are in and so it actually could
be a lot higher uh than we think and
then
the number could be hit but it could
also be like for example you talked
about the fact that we've got the sky
news list of who has said different
things out there i can remember a few
months ago um one of your reporters at
sky news saying that i hadn't supported
the prime minister because i hadn't
tweeted missing the fact that i was the
first minister out on tv supporting the
prime minister so look these lists are
their people have their things that
they'll say publicly i can remember as a
relatively new mp after david cameron
came into government as prime minister
and it was about 2011 2012 we had people
writing and saying they written letters
in back then this is something that does
happen i wish it didn't i think we
should all be focused on getting on with
the job i know in dealing with the prime
minister both on northern ireland issues
and more widely in cabinet that his
focus rightly is on getting things done
for people in the united kingdom
particularly at the difficult point
we're at where people are facing such
financial challenges a difficult point
that's reflected in some of the polling
and we've got this yougov um mrrp poll
it's the same model that predicted the
general election results and this has
shown that conservatives would lose all
but three of the 88 battleground seats
that you held hold by a slim margin over
labor
when you saw that how did you feel
as i've always done with polium i've
probably said this on your show before
that polling is a snapshot and first of
all we've got a fair way to go there's
not a general election in the next few
months it's you know could well be a
fair way away
it could be a fair way away and actually
there's a lot of work we are doing to
deliver for people and i hope by the
time we get to that general election
people will see
two key things one is that we have
delivered the prime minister's got those
big calls right and they'll see a
manifesto that's exciting about the
future but one other thing i would just
say is important on polling it is a
snapshot i can remember in the 2015 gym
election two or three days before
polling day a poll came out that told me
i was losing my seat to labour my
majority actually went up so we have to
remember that you know these polls are a
snapshot the work we do as
parliamentarians as campaigners can make
a very very big difference and i still
think we will win the next general
election and i think that's in the best
interest of the country it's interesting
when you said that a general election
won't be for the next few months is that
an acknowledgement that it could be a
bit earlier than we're expecting no no i
just mean this is a poll as of today
it's a snapshot of where we are today
but even if it was a snapshot of today
even if the general election was next
thursday we've had elections before
where the polls have been proven to be
out as i say i give that example in my
own constituency three or four two or
three days before polling in one
election told me i was going to lose by
a fair few percent and in fact my
majority went up so foreign because he's
down to lose his seat well and actually
if you remember going into 2019 there
were reports that the prime minister was
going to lose his c and that didn't
prove to be the case you know he's a
good uh member of parliament i think
he's a superb prime minister and if you
look at these big decisions whether it's
ukraine or through kovid he has got them
right and i think that is what we need
in our country uh now on friday boris
johnson amended the rules of the
ministerial code to make it clear that
ministers won't always be expected to
resign for breaching it and before um
doing this program my on twitter i asked
if there's any questions that people
would like to ask i know twitter is you
know twitter but still
i was quite surprised actually because
this subject came up more than any other
andrew simmons he wants you to explain
johnson's rewriting of the forward to
the ministerial code don't honesty
integrity transparency matter anymore
he's referring to the prime minister
removing those words from the forward
colm norton it would be nice to hear a
cabinet minister answer a question and
with the new ministerial rules he
wouldn't even have to resign for doing
so and why is the prime minister trying
to water down parliamentary standards
well it's not let's remember there's
been a bit of misinformation out there
about this first of all when the
ministerial code is updated which is
relatively regular and one of those
obviously has to fill in
all the members uh ministerial um
declarations and that's updated
regularly as well so whenever it's
updated quite regularly anyway but this
comes from the recommendations from the
from the commission and some of it from
lord god around
what there should be and this idea there
being a graduated penalty process
people still have to resign if they uh
commit
misleading the house or something
serious but there was a request from
from others including law guy and the
commission that we actually do have this
kind of graduated approach so it means
that if there's a minor infraction
whereas before there may be a decision
if there was a minor refraction in
theory that that's too minor to resign
then there's no penalty there are now a
series of penalties for different
infractions if anybody creates commits
an infraction in the first place labour
calling a vote on whether ministers who
commit serious breaches of the minister
or code should have to resign in other
words they're effectively forcing
conservative mps to put their name
to these changes it's going to feel
quite uncomfortable isn't it a bit
reminiscent of owen patterson perhaps um
how are you going to be voting i will
obviously look at the details of what
the vote is because these things the
wording of these can be quite important
but to me this feels like just labour
politicking over this they're just
playing games when actually what we
should be doing is focusing on the
issues that matter not the internal
naval gazing of westminster but actually
getting on with helping people as we did
this week the massive announcement from
the chancellor around the support for
people who are struggling with those
that global inflation challenge
making sure we're putting the support in
there as we are in northern ireland at
belfast with the in-laws coming out of
thailand to support people of ukraine in
these other issues whether it's
repairing making sure the money's there
if local authorities repair the potholes
that drive people crazy every day or the
bigger issues that are affecting their
pocket and their families that's what
they want to see government and
parliament focused on i think talking
about the um talking about the measures
announced by the chancellor he also
announced an energy profits levy on oil
and gas companies what most of us i
guess would call a windfall tax but we
can't use that term for the conservative
party for obvious reasons now you
previously said a windfall tax sounds
attractive but it doesn't work
if you quite conveniently change your
mind there no i haven't actually look i
believe in a low tax economy and what i
was the point i was making was that what
labour predict were asking for was a
straight winful tax that disincentivized
um
uh investment from companies actually
worried companies in other sectors and
you know actually some companies like
shelves said that your policy is going
to just okay let me just as well yeah i
don't know i've seen that but let me
just just finish the point and it also
meant very very little money actually to
go into people's pockets to help them
one of the things that was clear once we
we dug into this with labour's claims
were completely false what the
chancellor is ally is different
first of all i doubt many conservatives
are comfortable with taxes of any sort
we want to see a low tax economy more
people in people's pockets to drive
growth but we are in unprecedented times
and i've said before actually as we went
through kobe we were there to help
people and i think our track record is
in unprecedented times with a difficult
situation we would do what we can to
help what the chance of that is
different because the chancellor's
structure yes it does put that profit
levy on it's temporary uh it means much
more money coming back to help people
but he's also put in a tax break that
means that if those companies do what
they were meant to be doing which is
investing yeah then they get the tax
benefit that balances this out so it's
not exactly it's not a win for tax in
the sense the label put it's a much more
structured targeted approach that can
drive drive investment which we need in
that sector but also help people with
the challenges they're facing with the
cost of living due to global inflation
pressures you're talking about and
wanting to focus on the things that
matter to people
um the story that at the concept of
party pushing today is about imperial
measurements you know this kind of
classic you know story uh that seems to
come around every six two months to a
year now alyssia cairns at the
conservative mp has tweeted this morning
to say not one constituent ever has
asked for this this isn't a brexit
freedom it's a nonsense
well i've seen my constituency i've had
a different response of all their people
pleased about it and as you said this is
science comes up regularly through the
years people there are people who want
to go back and have that business
because the government say they're going
to do it i mean eight months ago tight
the times boris johnson is to announce
the return of imperial weights and
measures that was eight months ago
this is you know this isn't a week where
as i say we've done some major
legislation for north island we've done
major announcement uh to help people
with the cost of living you know one of
the biggest um
structural things we've done financially
for a very long time another 21 billion
pounds of support to help people and yes
look there is something in there that's
more light-hearted in terms of pill
measurements something people like look
i'm of an age where i still think in my
brain in two ways i will sometimes talk
in meters i'll also talk in feet uh
liters and pines miles and kilometers
and this just gives people the freedom
and for businesses and there are sectors
out there i know michael's teaching see
some of the the market traders and the
vegetable traders as well as some of the
pubs will be pleased to be able to go
back to those import measurements we're
just saying you now have a choice and
now we've left the eu we can do that yes
it's one of the smaller things we can do
as we left the eu and there are other
bigger things we can do we want to do
but it's an indication we now have the
freedom to make these decisions
ourselves just finally because we are at
a time and how concerned are you about
the scenes that we saw outside the
champions league final last night our
liverpool supporters saying they were
tear-gassed
yeah i heard some of this last night i
think it is concerning i think we do
need to ensure that they are looking
into how this happened it's not the
first time we've seen this overseas
actually and we're very lucky here in
the uk we've got a police force who have
specialism in this area they're very
very good at it and we've got to learn a
little bit about what happened over
there get to the bottom of it but it is
concerning to see that people either
didn't get into the stadium or were
treated in the way that they some of
them seem to have been treated with a
very aggressive approach liverpool want
to see an investigation do you think
that would be a good idea i think i can
understand that i think we will all want
to get to the bottom of how this
happened particularly it's not the first
time in the last years when i was
policing minister i remember overseas a
similar situation and we've got to make
sure that around the world we are using
the expertise that is there and how to
manage policing and the security around
uh
around football matches particularly so
you think perhaps the french police need
a bit more training well i'm sure that
the french will want to be looking into
this themselves it's not for me to get
involved in their domestic affairs but i
can understand why people want to get to
the bottom of this and i think all of us
as you know uk citizens who were there
will want to know that things were done
correctly and if they weren't how we
learn the lessons and how we're all
around the world know how we can police
and keep people safe at big sporting
events okay thank you very much indeed
brandon lewis on the programme
this morning
well the chancellor's announcement of
new measures on the cost of living that
we were just discussing uh there is a
potentially difficult moment for labour
they'll feel of course they force that
u-turn on a windfall tax the 15 billion
package of additional support though
especially targeted at lower earners has
been widely welcomed so what would
labour do differently we're joined now
by the party chair and shadow women and
equality secretary annelise dodds thank
you very much for being on the program
with us um i'll get to you know the
labor policies in a minute but we've
just heard from brandon lewis he says
he's got full confidence in the su grey
report despite the allegations in the
sunday times this morning uh do you
well i have to say the one person that
sadly we don't have confidence in is the
prime minister we now know because of
that report that he repeatedly lied to
parliament and his response as we've
seen over the last just couple of days
has been to try and actually change the
rules that he will then be judged by
because he's seeking to water down the
ministerial code that's the big issue
here and that's what labour's focused on
because for as long as we have boris
johnson at the head of government
currently we actually aren't seeing many
of the big issues being gripped onto by
the conservatives that government
continues to be in chaos and ultimately
working people are paying the price
at the same time though you're talking
there about how boris johnson has tried
to you know change the ministerial code
that he'll be judged by it is important
to say though isn't it that the most
serious offence is a misleading
parliament that what boris johnson has
been investigated for that would still
be a resignation issue so he wouldn't
necessarily benefit himself from the
changes that he's making
well unfortunately he has not resigned i
mean ultimately that is a sanction
that's only existing found guilty
well i think most people would draw
their own conclusions frankly seeing
what's it would be a bit strange for him
to resign before the investigation is
complete repeated denials
well
ultimately i think you're seeing many
conservative mps themselves having taken
that decision not enough of them i would
say but when it comes to the reform of
the ministerial code you know i think
the difference is very very clear you've
got boris johnson having removed the
words integrity accountability honesty
even from the forward to that code as i
say he has watered down the sanctions it
used to be previously the case that any
breaking of the ministerial code would
be a resignation issue neither other
sanctions that have been put in there
even just apologizing we're surely that
would be the very first thing that we
would expect that's not a sanction
that's just what ministers should do as
a function of course if they're found to
have broken the rules so we will be
forcing a vote on this we think that
ultimately politics should be clean they
should be a force for good we should
have all politicians held to high
standards that's why we're calling for
that vote
okay i'm keen to talk a little bit about
the cost of living at crisis because we
saw as i said in the introduction to you
we saw the conservative response uh this
week and it was widely welcomed you know
the ifs called it a big expensive
package which is hugely redistributive
taking from high earners and giving to
the poor the resolution foundations that
it rightly prioritizes those hit hardest
by the cost of living crisis you must
welcome the action that's been taken
well of course after five months of
calling for that windfall tax finally we
are relieved that the government appears
to have listened at least on that
subject but we are concerned that there
doesn't seem to be any plan now to deal
with the causes of that cost of living
crisis yes some action to deal with its
symptoms that we've called for as i said
for many months but not action to deal
with its causes i mean again labor's
called for many many months now for a
home insulation program that would take
400 pounds off people's bills not just
this year but in subsequent years into
the future as well again the other
measures that we need to see being taken
for our energy security labor's called
for example for a doubling of onshore
wind for tripling of solar and for an
end to the government's delay on new
nuclear we need those measures to be
taken urgently because they will deal
with the causes of some of this cost of
living crisis and not just the symptoms
you know it seems with this government
they tend to be dragged kicking and
screaming to action at the last minute
we need to see those longer term plans
now
it's interesting isn't it because i do
sometimes feel listening to labor and
that you want the government to go a
little bit more quickly on things that
it's already you know doing when it
comes to nuclear you're sort of saying
that they want to speed it up but the
government has committed to a nuclear
strategy if the big idea is you know
homes insulation that's something that
politicians have spoken about for an
awfully long time i mean your head of
labour's policy review that was launched
in june 2021 so it's been running for a
year now we're currently facing
an absolute cost of living crisis
inflation at a 40-year high potentially
the biggest drop in living standards
since records began what is the single
transformative idea that you've come up
with in this year-long policy review
well we've come up with many many ideas
if people are particularly interested
they can look at our reports on the
labour website and i have to say that
the core idea for labour is right now
when it comes to that cost of living
crisis as i said not just dealing with
the symptoms we set out that windfall
tax policy it took the government five
months to contemplate it they said that
it was unconservative they said they
wouldn't enact it they've been dragged
kicking and screaming to put it into
place but we're saying right we've got
to deal with those causes as well you
know we just talked about energy
security and labor's plan there yeah
just to come in because i did ask you
the one for growth
sorry to interrupt i did ask just going
to transformative policy what is
it well i was just going to to say and
sorry it's difficult when we're not in
the same place but i was going to say
when it comes to growth when we've had
such low growth under conservative leg
governments compared to under uh
previous labour governments that we're
very clear we've got to buy
make and sell
more in our country and that's what
rachel reeves has been setting out if we
do that then we can build growth back up
again because we've had far too low
levels of economic growth that's holding
back people's living standards and we've
set out exactly how we would be
delivering that so it really is labour
that's the party of ideas now the
conservatives have been dragged along in
the wake of what labour has been setting
out there and that's a big problem
because people are right up against it
right now and they need to see a
government that's on their side they
don't have that at the moment okay i
just want to move on to your women and
the qualities of brief to end uh stella
cruci the labour mp said in an interview
with telegraph yesterday do i think that
women were born with penises yes do you
agree with her
um well no i don't agree with her
biological females
obviously aren't of course there are
also
trans women who've made a transition in
their gender but sex is not the same as
gender but i would say that obviously i
have a huge amount of respect for my
colleague stella creasy she's done a
huge amount of campaigning for women but
on that issue around biology um i do
have a different opinion
um it's interesting this debate and you
know the last thing you want to do is
just to kind of try and get the kind of
shock questions or anything like that in
but there is a genuine debate that's
being had on what trans policy means
more widely so ella bravaman the
attorney general gave an interview with
the times this weekend where she was
speaking about how school should
accommodate trans pupils and of course
this is a live debate you know the
education secretary is drawing up
guidance
on single sex spaces so she was asked
whether pupils who were born male should
be able to use girls lavatories or
changing facilities
and she said i would say to the school
that they don't have to and that they
shouldn't they shouldn't allow that
child to go into girls toilets i think
protecting single sex spaces for
biological females and biological males
is really important particularly in
schools
what's your position on that
well of course it was labour that
created the equality act that provides
the legal
background for those single sex spaces
where they're needed but i have to say i
find this incredibly frustrating i mean
as you mentioned the government said
that it would produce guidelines to help
schools to help teachers on these issues
they haven't produced those guidelines
instead you've got ministers who are
taking up their time talking about these
different issues sounding off on them
not providing those guidelines and quite
frankly our attorney general when she's
presiding over such low levels record
low levels of prosecutions for rape and
actually making the situation worse now
by allowing actually the notes from
counselling sessions for rape victims to
be used to attack the credibility of
those victims i think she should get a
grip on that issue and focus on it and
ultimately if she's concerned about the
situation in school she should be
getting her education colleagues to
hurry up and produce the guidelines that
they said they would provide because all
children all children need to be safe in
school
okay thank you uh very much indeed
annelise dawd's uh there thank you thank
you
now the rmt union has vowed to bring the
country to a standstill as railway
workers voted overwhelmingly for strike
action across the network it could mean
the biggest railway stoppage for decades
with action across network rail and 13
train companies the timetable could be
just 20
of normal now it's a sign of the
worsening industrial relations across
the economy as workers seek big pay
rises given the record rate of inflation
well mick lynch is the general secretary
of the rmt and joins us now thank you
very much for being with us here in the
studio
um so you've told the telegraph you're
going to be striking from the north of
scotland down to the tip of cornwall why
do you want to see strike action
we don't want strike action this is a
defensive action against the companies
and the government in fact who are
bringing in stringent cuts thousands of
jobs of our members some thousands have
already gone
and they're thousands more to go
they also want to completely change the
conditions that our members have agreed
with their employers
and we haven't had a pay rise for a very
long time many of our members are now on
the third anniversary of not having a
pay rise they worked all the way through
covid
they mainly had to work
at work not staying at home working
online
and they're fed up with it they want to
have job security they want to provide a
service for the public but we do need a
pay rise to keep up with the rocket and
inflation that we're all experiencing
you say that you need a pay rise and the
average uk salary is 31 000 pounds the
average railway salary is 45 000 pounds
that's not correct what's the correct
number the median salary for a railway
worker that we represent is 31 000
pounds it's exactly not with the average
um so
given the fact that you know it is in
line with the average and why some
people you know look at watching and
listening to this will be wondering why
it is that you do deserve a pay rise
ahead of others well all british workers
deserve a pay rise there's a bit of a
nonsense that goes around especially in
the media that says
if we get a pay rise somehow
other workers won't get a pay rise or if
we don't get a pay rise it will be
transferred
to nurses to to other public sector
workers and people that are also being
exploited that just won't happen if we
don't get a pay rise the profits of the
companies will just go up and what needs
to happen in the uk is that some of
these profits need to be reduced so that
british workers can get a pay rise every
worker in this country is struggling at
the moment they can't keep up with the
utility prices they can't keep up with
their household bills we need a pay rise
but we also need job security because
there's a lot of precarious work and
vulnerable work at the moment and that's
got to end if you're saying that
everyone deserves a pay rise you're not
worried about the impact that this could
have on inflation which is you know the
very thing that everyone's really
concerned about you know the bank of
england governor andrew bailey calling
for pay restraint because well his pay
restraint he's on 600 000 pounds a year
as he's the chief of network rail there
are railway bosses taking home millions
of pounds every year the railways made
500 million pound of profit last year
when uh fares and passengers were at an
all-time low people are stripping money
out of the railway they're stripping
money out of the economy and if workers
wages don't go up it means a transfer of
wealth from the poor to the rich we've
got more billionaires than we've ever
had in this country the rich have never
been richer and the reason they're able
to do that and get richer all the time
is because they're deliberately
depressing workers wages inflation has
come on board now and virtually nobody's
had a pay rise for the last two or three
years so this idea that there's a wages
price spiral is nonsense i totally get
um
and i'm sure many of our viewers will
share you know your assessment of the
very very high wages particularly the
high wages of those people calling for
pay restraint
but it doesn't change the facts though
does it that if if lots of people get
pay rises then it could lead to
inflation well inflation is already here
and nobody said more inflation well it
could lead to more inflation but what
could also stop inflation is that some
of the companies could restrain their
profits and return that money into lower
prices bp and shell on the others are
making record profits of billions of
pounds every quarter and everyone yearly
they don't got so much money they don't
know what to do with it one of the
things they could do is sacrifice those
profits never mind a windfall tax what
about a dividend that goes back to the
people that are consuming their their
materials but also we've got thousands
and thousands if not millions of people
who are struggling and while they're
working and having to take benefits
that's an outrage the reason they have
to take benefits is they're not being
paid enough
and they need to be paid more okay
now just talking about the strike action
do you think it's now that inevitable
well we're talking to the companies
we're talking to the companies at a very
senior level but they are taking a very
hard line they want to impose these cuts
while they're imposing record increases
in fares
their
fare increases are linked to the retail
price index
wages on the question is do you think
the strikes are inevitable i can't see a
way out from the strikes at the moment
unless there's a breakthrough unless the
government instructs these companies
which they are doing to to change their
line rather than harden their line it's
very very likely that they'll be strike
action and it will be very soon and what
what level of pay increase would you
like to see for your members well i'll
negotiate that with the companies
there's a lot of ways to put value into
a package just give us a rough idea well
we want to see something that reflects
the ever-increasing costs our
anniversaries for these companies were
back in december and back in
april so does that mean you'd like to
see it roughly the same level as
inflation well it needs to meet the
aspirations of our members which
coincide with inflation yes so roughly
around the level that inflation
currently is well that's what they need
to do to keep up otherwise our people
become poorer eight to ten percent well
we'll talk to the companies about that
okay uh now millions of people across
the country are gearing up to
make good use of the extra bank holidays
to celebrate the queen's
jubilee and and yet their plan strikes
on the london underground
well there's not we called off a strike
next friday we've got a way forward on
that which is on one of the public
holidays so there's no strike action by
the rmt over any of the queen's jubilee
celebrations on both the june the 3rd
and june the 6th or june 6th is after
the celebration okay but it's still on
the back holiday though isn't it well
the bank holidays thursday and friday
this is a normal work day on the monday
okay right so you all right okay that's
where we are
you've you've you've caught up one of
the strike actions but how how worried
are you about the disruption that it
could cause people and the sympathy that
you might get well we don't want
disruption it's a hard road being a
trade unionist and taking industrial
action but we feel we have no choice the
london mayor is attacking our people
he's attacking their pensions he wants
to make them poorer permanently not just
while they're at work but while they're
in retirement it's exactly the same
agenda that the government's putting
forward through these funding
negotiations with the companies and with
the london mayor we cannot sit idly by
as a trade unionist while while our
people are being attacked
while they're at work while they finish
when they finish work for retirement and
very threat that they may lose their
jobs it's my job as a trade union leader
to defend our people and this is a
defensive strike if it happens their
tanks are on our lawn we're not
threatening them they're threatening our
people you're looking ahead to the
summer do you think we could see you
know a summer of discontent well there
are a lot of workers that are very upset
i'm seeing that there's action going on
in the local councils we've got refuse
workers we've got care workers
most people who come from traditional
working-class environments find
themselves super exploited not only they
got poor wages they've got poor
conditions if they've got any conditions
but they also find themselves under the
threat of cuts
and that being job cuts so there has to
be a response from all of the trade
unions and from the tuc and we would
like to see the labour party and its
leadership coming behind working-class
people so that they ensure they get a
pay rise so there's some support from
the politicians as well as from the
trade unions and this this is a measure
for kia stammer so that he can decide
whether he's on the side of the workers
in this country or on the side of the
bosses do you think that he hasn't made
that clear then he hasn't made it clear
at all i've not heard him say once uh
during the current dispute such as at
the coventry uh council where the labour
council sought to cut workers wages and
cut their conditions i've seen no
response from the labour front bench
that says
we support the workers in their
struggles and that is the role of a
labour party the name gives it away that
there's support they're there to support
the labour movement do you think that
kirsten was on the side of workers i
can't see it at the moment
wow and to say what do you think that
means for the you know the funding of
the labour party and the union support
for the local well my union's not
affiliated with the labour party but i
see many other unions general
secretaries and leaders thinking what is
the point of this connection if we just
get this bland democratic party sitting
in the center of
politics
taking their their instructions off the
daily mail to some extent and not
actually getting behind workers
struggles you have to ask yourself why
do they call themselves the labour party
so we need to see a strong line the
labour party needs to get back into
working class communities support better
wages and support the end of precarious
work which is outsourced subcontracted
and vulnerable work where you don't know
where you're going to get your next
week's work from in terms of these
flexible hours contracts and zero hours
contracts and all the rest of it so they
have to make a stand for working people
and i guess what kirsten would say is
that he's looked at the last uh election
results when there was a more left-wing
leader and it was a catastrophic set of
results for the labour party and that it
hit up to him to try and re-engage with
some of those people who turned away
from labor yeah some of those people
that have turned away from labor are the
people who have not got any decent job
security in this economy now if he wants
to go back to the red wall and now the
blue wall he's got to make a connection
with working people and one of those
things is about the fact that there's no
decent housing being built by councils
the fact that people cannot rely on an
income and the fact that they're
underpaid and this is a crisis and it's
time for kieran to stand up for our
people okay just uh finally um you have
previously said that you can't rule out
four-day strikes are you concerned about
what a four-day strike could look like
for this country so you know for example
you know if they could lead to even the
lights going out because of disruption
to services drax power station north
yorkshire servicing millions of homes
and there's only a certain amount of uh
of
power that it can stockpile are you
concerned i'm concerned about disruption
i don't want disruption and nor do my
members but they don't want to see their
conditions stripped out and they don't
want to live under an ever-present
threat of job cuts
network rail have already announced that
two and a half hours of my people will
be made redundant they've already made
1500 job cuts in that company and that's
the first installment now we're going to
see a stripped-out dehumanized railway
if we're not careful if the companies
want to come back to the table and work
with us to get a proper settlement we
can do that very quickly and there
wouldn't need to be any strikes at all
do you think it genuinely could lead to
the lights going out i've got no idea it
depends how long the strike goes on if
there is strike action then it's up to
the government to give a mandate to the
companies that they can settle this
dispute how long could the strikes be
they could go on for a very very long
time because there's no sign at the
moment that anybody's backing down on
their side of the table
we'll decide that as we go we want to
make the strike action if it happens as
effective as possible from our point of
view but just you are prepared to strike
for long enough that it could affect the
power supply if you don't get you to
have your demands matters our members
are prepared to take effective strike
action in pursuit of the settlement of
this dispute i've got no idea how long
that will take and i can't determine
from here what the what the outcomes and
side effects of that will be okay um
doesn't sound like you're ruling that
out at all uh thank you uh very much
indeed mick lyncher or the rmt thank you
now iceland is well known for selling
low-cost frozen food and it's popular
among shoppers on lower incomes but in a
sign of just how tough things are the
supermarket is losing customers to food
banks that's people of course who can no
longer afford to buy what they need to
eat the chancellor has unveiled a new
package of measures that the treasury
says is worth some 1 200 pounds to those
on lowest the lowest incomes but is it
enough and just how much worse could
things get this winter well we are
joined now by richard walker who is the
managing director of iceland and can you
just talk to us a little bit about you
know the typical iceland shopper and how
difficult they're finding things now
well the reality is there is no uh
typical ice and chopper averages don't
work very well because we have people
who who come in and spend five quid and
people who come in and spend 50 quid um
but yeah generally i think it's safe to
say that everyone is is feeling the
pinch now doesn't matter who you are um
now we we do serve um some of the poorer
demographics around the country and we
are hearing stories as you said of some
um some of our custom disappearing to
food banks which is a reality or indeed
some customers um when they're at the
till asking the cashier when it amounts
to 40 quid so that they can leave the
rest of their shopping um we're seeing
people trading to the best value
packs and products um so yeah i think
it's it's fair to say that everyone's
feeling the pinch but certainly the
harder press communities are feeling it
more than anyone you know it really does
take a picture of just how difficult so
many people are finding it and of course
inflation a big concern over the board
but grocery price inflation
uh in particular a real worry as they
hit a 13-year high um can you just give
us a bit of a sense about what specific
foods so
arising by and how much
yeah um again it's you know there's
there's no one particular metric what's
interesting about that food inflation
figure um the the median kind of food
inflation figure of seven eight percent
um it includes things like champagne and
legs of lamb um now some of our
customers certainly aren't buying that
and um the reality is that you know the
basic staples are increasing more we've
seen as you'll know loaf of bread which
is now one pound ten it probably was
about 89 p
milk
across all retailers has has gone up uh
quite dramatically it's across the board
and that's because there's a perfect
kind of maelstrom of inflationary
pressures from commodity um price
increases uh through to labor shortages
in in the fields and factories and
through to the price of fuel to uh to
move goods around uh through to genuine
supply shortages like um uh sunflower um
or wheat and both of which come from
ukraine and for obvious reasons you know
both of those uh things have have dried
up and the unintended consequences of
that it's not just a bottle of sunflower
oil or the wheat in your bread um
sunflower oil finds its way as a
vegetable fat into hundreds of different
ready meals and pre-prepared meals
and wheat goes into animal feed so that
is having a knock-on consequence of the
price of everything from bacon to
chicken
it's interesting talking though about
ukraine and the prime minister and
president zolensky spoke just a couple
of days ago about the impact of the
blockage of the port of odessa and the
supply of of grain around the world and
just looking forward to how concerned
are you about the impact that this could
have and how much do you think food
could actually go up by in the months
ahead
look um you know
there's people far cleverer than me who
are forecasting this stuff um i think
it's impossible to say i think from
where we are at the moment i'm not
gravely concerned around supply issues
uh i and i think if you look at our own
business we are especially resilient as
a frozen first retailer um we we can
build up stocks we have uh long
supply lines which um which we've been
working on two years worth of shelf life
so we're we're very resilient and as a
private family business we can invest in
the right places for our customers and
that's why we're doing a ton of
different offers and deals and
promotions and value packages just to
try and help through our customers
last week for example on tuesday we ran
our first over 60s discount of 10
percent
which was unbelievably well received um
by
our um some of our customers and we've
held the price of all of our one pound
lines to the end of the year that's a
major investment by us because the price
the cost of those goods have gone up so
we're making no money on those now but
we think it's the right thing to do
and we've reduced the threshold of our
home delivery because that service is
more important than ever for people who
can't afford to drive into town centers
and spend the money on fuel um and
rather to take their free home delivery
service so there's loads of different
things that we can do it's certainly not
going to get any easier i don't know how
how much worse it's going to get um but
hopefully uh
ourselves and our competitors are
resilient enough to to get through it
for our customers
yeah certainly some concerning times
ahead the government unveiled its big
support package this week to help
families is there anything specifically
that you would like to see the
government do
going forward to try and help tackle you
know the rising cost of food
do you know what i must say you know i
think the government the chancellor in
particular has um has really uh
stepped up and and
you know pulled the right levers uh they
already had over 20 billion pounds of
support before this additional 20
billion pounds of latest packages so
certainly huge intervention there by the
government and actually we've got to
take a step back and realize that you
know a lot of these pressures are global
in nature and um a lot of these
pressures are outside of
the influence of of the government of
the day or businesses like ours so i
think they've
they've done plenty actually for the
general public and hopefully it will
ease the pain and the burden as we get
into the autumn as as
inflation may peak and there's a ton of
stuff i'd like him to do for business um
i don't know how he's going to
afford it um or we're all going to pay
for it um but i think at the moment
they're doing a good job
thank you uh very much really
interesting to talk and get your
perspective and to hear some of those
stories about how shoppers are coping
thank you thank you
now to ukraine and when vladimir putin's
forces first invaded her country kyra
rudik's first thought was no pilates
today well then she went into parliament
and she voted to create martial law as
the country plunged into war and then
she went to pick up a rifle she says
that military training is a good workout
but putting bullets into guns ruins the
manicure the ukrainian mp is in the uk
at the moment she's meeting politicians
here i'm delighted to say she joins us
now it's a real pleasure to
have you here um you know
we've heard from a lot of you know
amazing ukrainian women over the weeks
um but you know to actually meet
somebody as they're traveling to the uk
is that you know it is a privilege to
say thank you so thank you thank you um
now you're part of the resistance
in ukraine you know as i said in the
introduction you know you kind of joked
that training is a good workout but it's
not great for the manicure you know how
to shoot a gun you've been training for
two hours a day can you just talk a bit
about your experience your life must
have completely
changed since the announcement of war
yeah it absolutely
changed and
the setting it will never be the same
again
you know
i was traveling right now by the time
path as ukraine refugees do when they
leave ukraine
and everybody was so great along the way
uh in poland and moving forward and here
in the uk
uh so uh on the first morning i was
jogging in warsaw
and there was an ambulance passing by
with we we will and i realized that in
one minute i'm on the ground with my
head hovering my head
and so for the last three months
i have been standing still doing
everything possible and impossible i
realized that the trauma
that ukrainian people are getting that
i'm getting is something that
that is there that will never go away
this is what we are talking about when
we are saying that
the trauma on our children in different
ages would be something
that is irreparable
and it's for generation right now you
know like uh we were hoping that we will
raise up all the children that don't
know the poverty the war the revolutions
that we would spoil them and make sure
that they will be
uh when they will be grown up they will
be able to build new advanced ukraine
and right now we are robbed of that
and my life in ukraine as politician as
a member of resistance
um
it's just completely different from
anything i could have ever imagined what
is it like can you give us an insight
like where are you living what was the
typical day
so i i stay at home
i still have resistance members staying
with me
they are training and i'm training with
them
we are training to shoot we are training
some some
advancements and how to protect the
territory where we are we are right now
part of the major resistance
of kiev region and some of the people
have been already deployed to war
and some of the members of my team will
also be redeployed soon
i cook something that i never have done
before we still have
one month supplies of food and water at
home
because it's so scary you know
the scary thing was there will be no
water and i was thinking i don't want to
die dirty so i have like lots of water
everywhere i actually like to yeah
no but this is something when you're
talking to refugees from haki from
heavily bombarded areas when they are
saying uh well like the the most
complicated thing was when the
electricity went down when the water
went went off so like what are you what
are you supposed to do you have to get
ready for everything i have
so i have chargers and power banks
everywhere and make sure that they are
charged in case uh in case we will have
to use them so you live in this constant
inability to exhale
and say okay yeah we are safe right now
because every single day
there are air raid sirens there are
attacks on kiev and on other major
cities of ukraine and the war it did not
go anywhere they're active fighting went
to the east but the threat
the fear
it is still there as you said that that
is a fear that you will always bear with
you at least yes yeah that's that's
something that that is already with me
and i realized it so strongly right now
um do you think you'll ever feel safe
again
well
here i feel safe but i will have to come
back home because this is the fight that
we have to put up and we have to win
and
i dream of the day when when all
ukrainians will be able to feel safe we
will you know be able to sit
put your
uh hands
on your lap and say yeah okay
we are okay now
and more important is that our children
will be able to do so
because right now so yes there was at
the protest in the downing streets at
the rallies of ukrainian people and
people say we feel
so uncomfortable that we had to leave we
feel so great that people are
supporting us but we feel guilty that we
had to leave and i say don't
you make sure that your children are not
going through this terror they are not
going through this trauma and you need
to make sure that they are safe and this
is what your obligation as a parent to
make them safe
this is why i am telling to ukrainian
people wherever you are we are all
together we are standing together and we
are supporting our country and every
single person is doing it their own way
and this is why
uh it's so important is this why this
trip is so important that i was able to
talk to them and to support them and to
hear from them
um let's talk a bit about the visit as
you say you've been meeting uh
politicians here in the uk what is it
specifically you've been asking for and
if you had any reassurances so
i'm having actually important meeting
with the defense committee tomorrow
and before that there are three things
that i'm actually asking for
the first one is the
wide-range missiles this is something
that we critically need to make sure
that we fight russians back you have
heard that they have been advancing in
the east and we do need more weapons and
we need specific weapons that we know
that will help us
the second point is
the uh
visa vapor for ukrainians there is you
know
united kingdom is very far from ukraine
there are not so many people getting in
but for the ones who are
uh i i'm
humbly asking for making it easier on
them what what is the process like is it
too bureaucratic we haven't had a
bureaucratic it's long and uh and it's
complicated and these are refugees who
might not yeah they don't have the
paperwork yes and you see like um
britain has been one of our closest
allies so ukrainians right now travel
without visas through the eu uh there
are the processes have been eased up for
us and canada so it's just a question
mark for me why united kingdom wouldn't
do the same it would be just only
natural and again we are we are talking
about maybe 20 000 people who would get
it eased up
so on them so i think this is completely
doable and the third thing is sorry
about the ports
so before the war
ukraine was top three producers of the
world grains sunflower oil
wheat
for tomatoes and corn so tell me which
ones you don't like which ones you don't
want to get rid of and so right now it
is all blocked in ukraine and we are
unable to to actually deliver it
anywhere because of the blocked ports so
there is an extreme need right now to
get into humanitarian mission to be able
to extract all this produce i have
talked to people here i know you guys
are having already uh higher food prices
which we just talked about just the yeah
sunflower oil is missing from the stores
you know why because it's all in ukraine
right now and the world right now has
only 10 weeks
supplies
of grains 10 weeks for all the
politicians all the leaders of the world
to make sure that you figure out how to
how to get all the harvest that ukraine
has out so these are the three key
points that i'm pushing that i'm working
on to make sure that uh that they
actually make a real difference so it's
not like a political discussions it's
rather the executional discussions let's
get on that and do that it's interesting
to listen to those three points it feels
like with two of those points the uk
government is very on board with we've
been one of the leading supplier of
weapons we know that boris johnson has
spoken specifically to president
zielinski about the port situation
i guess
is it the middle situation that the visa
requirement that you think the uk is
doing the worst on
of these three points probably it's just
like at the bottom of the list because
uh as my argument that there is not too
many people who need this waiver and the
government's argument as well there is
not too many people like let them go
through the process but
i met those people i know them they they
are all people who just are they just
need the support people are not coming
to united kingdom to get like support
from the government they usually come in
here because they have relatives or they
have friends or they have somebody to
support do you think there's a
reluctance with this government to to
open up the visa requirements there is
some i think it's just like saying okay
it's not in in our priorities and that's
why yeah
yeah well i want to make it a priority
okay um and just finally um
you know it's always difficult talking
about the specifics of what is happening
in ukraine i find it difficult to to
listen to i'm sure our viewers find it
difficult to listen to as well but there
is an importance to to bear witness and
to for ours to to tell the world about
what is happening
you know you were speaking very movingly
about children and the impact on
children at the beginning of the
interview and i just wondered if you
wanted to leave
us with any examples of the kind of
thing that children are experiencing in
ukraine
i can give a couple of examples so
at the very beginning of the war in the
bomb shelter
there was a toddler
whose mummy told him his blood type
so he's barely speaking and when he's
asked what's your blood type he's saying
there is a girl who was asking her mommy
the question that nobody can answer for
real mommy are we refugees now
how are you supposed to to talk to your
kid about that
and there were these uh group of
children refugees from mariupol who were
handed over like without their parents
and their parents were giving them the
backpacks the small ones the blue for
boys and the painful girls and they were
putting
like the the small bare minimum there
and when and mommies when they were
handing them over to strangers saying
just get them safe they were telling
hold on no matter what happens hold on
to your backpack and then when at the
refugee center you are hugging this
child and you are telling like give it
to me like please let's open up and
watch what's there. and he's saying no
mommy told me not to do that he told me
to do this and would i ever see my mommy
again and then when you open up
you know like the same same thing as
probably what happened during the world
second world war when they were writing
down like the small things like saying
mommy loves you
this is his last name first name this is
his paperwork this is our address and
please please please please please make
him safe
this is what i want for ukrainian
children to make them safe
thank you so much
thank you thank you for coming on the
program i'm sorry i'm very emotional um
but you know it's it's hard to hear
face-to-face some of what happening
thank you thank you
that is it uh for safety ridge on sunday
uh this week what a moving uh interview
to finish with um we really thank you
for coming on the programme
and talking about that
uh sophie ridge on sunday the podcast uh
will be available of course later on uh
today
around lunchtime that is usually
available
thanks for watching see you next week